[Music]
hello this is an interview with jesse
moo who is the first author of the paper
improving intrinsic exploration with
language abstractions this paper is
really cool because it combines the
knowledge that is inherent in language
with the problem of exploration in
reinforcement learning i've made a
comprehensive review of this paper in
the last video so be sure to check that
out my guest today jesse has seen the
video and we're able to dive right into
the questions criticisms and anything
that came up during the video the
interview was super valuable to me i
learned a lot i hope you do too if you
like then please leave a like on the
video tell me what you think in the
comments tell me how i can make these
videos better
above all else and i'll see you around
bye bye
hi everyone today i'm here with jesse
moo who is the first author of the paper
improving intrinsic exploration with
language abstractions which is really
cool paper i've enjoyed reading it
i like the bringing language into the
reinforcement learning domain i think it
makes a lot of sense and i was very
happy to see this paper yeah jesse
welcome to the channel yeah thanks for
having me
so
uh i've i've presumably the viewers here
have already seen my my little review of
the paper uh what would be
your maybe for people who haven't seen
that or just in your words your like
short elevator pitch of the paper itself
what would that be
yeah so
the way that i would pitch the paper is
that
reinforcing learning for a while now has
wrestled with perhaps the central
problem which is
how do we encourage exploration
in
these environments with more complex
tasks and longer time horizons where
the extrinsic reward that you get from
the environment is very sparse so
in the absence of extrinsic awards how
do we encourage agents to explore
and typically the way we do so is we you
know assume and this is a very
cognitively appealing intuition that we
should motivate an agent to achieve
novelty in the environment right we
should uh make it do things that it
hasn't done before encounter states that
it hasn't seen before etc and then
hopefully will enable the agent to
acquire
the skills that we actually want the
agent to acquire in the environment but
the problem with this of course is how
we define novelty
in a lot of scenarios you know there are
environments that can look very
different but they have the same
underlying semantics so the example i
have in the paper is like you know a
kitchen and the appliances might be
differently branded and differently
colored but
ultimately every kitchen is a kitchen
and you know the way that you approach
kitchens in the way that you operate in
them is the same
and so the idea of this paper is
we should be using natural language as a
the measure for how we describe states
and how we describe actions within
states and
use kind of traditional approaches to
exploration reinforcement learning but
simply parameterize them with language
rather than with state abstractions
which is usually the way in which
exploration is done in these kinds of
environments and so what we do is we
take existing state-of-the-art
exploration methods
and then kind of see what happens when
you swap in language as a component
right and do you get better performance
and we showed that you know in a variety
of settings at least in the kinds of rl
environments that
people have been looking at in recent
work we do see again in using language
to primarize exploration rather than
states
yeah that is uh i think it's it's it's
uh very apt to describe this um
apt to describe it as
you
it's not suggesting like a new
exploration algorithm but it's simply
the re-parameterization in terms of
language and coincidentally these
environments they do come with this kind
of language annotations which we do
focus on i like the so i think what i
really liked about this paper is just
the research mindset in that any other
paper or a lot of other papers they
would have done they would have tried
doing like three things at the same time
like you know we we have a language
generator and we do this and we do that
and what you're i think doing correctly
from a standpoint of of research is you
keep pretty much everything constant the
algorithms constant right even the the
environments you assume
that you have a perfect language oracle
and you just add the language which i i
really appreciate as like uh a reviewer
let's say um
so
i think this gets us right into our
or my
biggest
essentially criticism of the paper or
what i what i called in that
you add language to these algorithms but
you just said we swap in language and to
me it felt more like it's not really a
swapping in it's more like you add
language on top of what these algorithms
are doing and therefore
um can't i just see your method as
adding more data essentially there is
features that are available from the
simulator right which the other message
just don't use they just discard this
part and you just add this part uh do
you have an indication you know how much
of your effect is really due to language
and how much of the effect is just due
to the fact that you have more data
available yeah that's a that's a great
question and it's definitely a point
that
i think a lot of people will fairly make
against the paper uh is yeah we're using
extra data right
and
yeah i think my verb swap was maybe only
accurate in half of this paper which is
that you know in amigo which is the
first method that we look at it really
is a swap right so uh
if you read the paper um the traditional
kind of amigo teacher network proposes
coordinates
xy positions as goals and here we're
just completely you know eliminating
that kind of goal specification and
we're moving towards language so so that
can be seen as more of a swap
although of course in
novelty which is the second
method that we look at that is
definitely more of kind of an addition
as you say because we keep the extrinsic
bonus and we do have experiments um that
measure what happens if you don't have
novelty by itself you only have the kind
of language novelty bonus and it doesn't
do as well so you're right that um
you know i would say that we explore
like this idea of swapping in language
and in a bit of the paper but there are
points where it's more of kind of a
bolt-on and we're not like super clearly
looking at you know or distinguishing um
when is it okay to have language you
know just be a complete drop-in
replacement versus just some additional
information so yeah i think i think uh
we're showing that you know in general
like if you're if you're trying to add
language into these environments you're
seeing a gain
but how precisely that that gain
manifests um is you know still still
requires some more exploration for sure
um so i guess more generally to your
comment on using extra data
um
yeah i mean i think
we have some intuition that that this
data should help right it's a it's a
fairly clean linguistic signal
but how to use this data concretely is
an open question right and so that's
kind of where i view the contribution of
this paper as even though we have some
intuition that adding extra data will
help we actually need the equations
written down right and here are two
concrete ways in which we can
operationalize this data for the
purposes of actually getting better
performance in your environment um and
there are a lot of examples of this in
machine learning right so like you have
some large language model for example
and then you want to fine-tune it for
some domain or you want to fine-tune it
on human preferences i mean that's
fundamentally you know you're adding
extra data for the purposes of getting
something that works well on a task that
you care about right and how to use that
data is the open question
the other point that i would say is that
you know we have some deep-seated
intuition that this language should help
as you say it's really high quality it
comes from an oracle it comes from the
game engine um but we actually still
need to get that kind of empirical
verification that it works right and
there's actually a lot of reasons why
maybe
these experiments might not have worked
out uh for example the language is
oracle generated as i mentioned but uh
it is also very noisy so as i described
in kind of the the method section of the
paper
most of the messages that you see in the
environments are actually not necessary
to complete the extrinsic task you know
and i kind of exhaustively like show
like which of the messages do matter um
and so it could be the case that well
you know the language signal at least in
these environments is too noisy um the
state abstraction captures all the
factors of variation that you might care
about in an environment and so you don't
ultimately need language right and
that's that's an imperial question that
we have to measure uh and so i view this
paper as providing that empirical
verification which in hindsight i think
is a fairly straightforward intuition
you know it's something that i
definitely thought would happen um but
yeah it's nice to see those results kind
of in writing
yes it's easy i think you're right it's
easy to look back and say of course like
well all you do is you know you know you
do this but
exploration has been
since since you know people have thought
about reinforcement learning they've
obviously thought about exploration
methods and and intrinsic rewards are
like as old as schmidt hoover himself
and uh we you know
the the fact is that you know new things
are developed and this is at least one
of the first things into into really the
direction of incorporating uh
there have been incorporation of
languages before but a systematic adding
it to the state-of-the-art methods and
yeah it seems like i'm i am convinced
the method at least the el amigo method
is is quite well outlined i think in
these diagrams the contrast of the left
being the original amigo and the right
side being the uh language amigo
the question i had right here is that on
the left side you have this teacher
network and it simply outputs a
coordinate to reach and it has to pay
attention to the fact that the
coordinate
is not too hard and not too easy right
um
therefore it has to
learn
that too easy coordinate uh yeah i said
one that is you know close but also it
has to learn maybe unreachable
coordinates or coordinates that are
inside the walls right they can't be
reached or something like this however
on the right side in the language amigo
you seem to split these two tasks out
into uh one network that that determines
which goals can even be reached and one
that then orders them essentially why
why are you doing
this like what's the is there a
particular reason behind why one network
couldn't do both at the same time
yeah so
the reason why we split the el amigo
network up into two parts um and as you
say we don't have to do this and there
are ablation studies in the appendix
that shows what happens if you uh get
rid of the grounding and you just have a
single network predicting both
goal achievability and you know
actual uh the actual goal that's seen by
the students so kind of a goal
difficulty network
it does fine in some environments
especially in a mini hack but it doesn't
do as well in other environments such as
mini grid and part of the reason as
you've described is that um at least in
these environments the coordinate space
stays consistent across episodes and so
you're right that there are some
coordinates that are uh perhaps
unreachable in certain environments and
not in others but there's much less
variation than uh the set of language
goals that are achievable in an
environment because the environment will
have different colored doors for example
and so the goal go to the red door only
makes sense in let's say half of your
environments
so it's possible for the teacher to the
el amigo teacher to hopefully learn this
distinction um kind of just through
you know the policy gradient method so
basically just like amigo but this is
relatively sample and efficient because
the problem is that when you propose a
goal that's simply impossible in the
environment and you get negative reward
that negative reward only comes after
the the student has tried to complete
the goal for let's say a few hundred
steps right and so it's a relatively
simple inefficient way of telling the
teacher hey the student did not achieve
this goal in the environment and
moreover that negative reward you know
there's two possible sources of that
reward right so if if the student never
completed the goal is it the case that
uh it was just too difficult for the
student but it is you know achievable in
practice or is it that um the goal is
simply never achievable in the first
place in the environment right and those
kind of two failure cases are a little
bit hard to distinguish
whereas we have kind of this more
frequent source of supervision which is
simply you know as the student is
randomly exploring in the environment
it's encountering a lot of goals a lot
of messages because we have a language
annotator
and we're kind of you know if we if we
kind of ignore that signal that seems
like something that we should be using
and so we have kind of this dual thing
where we have a grounding number which
is updated more frequently in the
environment which is updated from the
messages that are seen by the students
and then finally the policy network
which is actually trained to satisfy the
kind of difficulty objective and
actually get the student to complete
goals in the environment
can you go a little bit more into
because that was i think the only part
that confused me a little bit which is
that how exactly you train this
grounding network uh there is a there is
this um this notion of whatever the
first language description encountered
along a trajectory being sort of the
positive sample and then the rest being
the negative samples in and that kind of
confused me because it means the
negative samples would also include
goals that were encountered just not as
the first message um could you maybe
clarify maybe i didn't understand
something right or maybe i don't uh
you know
see the the reasoning behind this exact
choice
yeah so no i think your intuition is
correct i think you've described it
correctly um it is kind of a weird thing
to do which is that we are
treating negative samples as basically
all of the goals besides the first one
that was achieved right and of course
that is
incorrectly
uh treating negative samples of goals
that were achieved later right so yeah
these negative samples
um are noisily generated as i as i say
um in the limit this noise should even
out though so it you can compare you
know like we're just kind of noisily
generating negative samples here we can
compare that to maybe a setting where we
had a more oracle sense of uh when a
goal is truly infeasible in an
environment right um and so what happens
is you know just in general a goal is
going to appear in this negative sample
term more and more often as we train the
network but because it's a um we're kind
of you know downwarding all possible
goals in the space um the idea is that
hopefully you know then this noise of of
class incorrectly classifying a goal is
unachievable in an environment kind of
evens out over time right um and so yeah
it's a little bit tricky because we
don't have the oracle saying oh you
can't achieve this goal in an
environment right we only know that uh
well you know the student just didn't
happen to achieve the goal in this
environment so i could imagine other
ways in which we try to come up with
some heuristic that better captures this
idea of kind of
unachievability um but this is what we
came up with which seems to work
reasonably well in practice
an alternative way that you can
interpret this is
we're not really measuring
true achievability like you know is this
at all possible in an environment what
we're really trying to have the
grounding network capture here is what
are the goals that the student tends to
reach so like are feasible at the
current state of training right the
current policy what goals can it reach
um and that's really what we need right
is we need like to propose goals that at
least for now are
eventually reachable by a student
and that doesn't mean that it's you know
uh unachievable in all possible students
under all possible environments but at
least just for current um you know in
the current stage of the training
process it's a reasonable target
i can imagine that this gets very
at this may require an adjustment or
that this breaks down in environments
that are more causally structured for
example if i always have to go through
the green door before i reach the red
door right then the goal would always be
in any trajectory that i do the green
door would always be the first goal and
therefore my grounding network would
never recognize that the red door as a
reachable goal because that's always
going to be at least the second goal
right so i guess depending on the
environment it's not hard to make a
change to this obviously uh in that case
but i guess that's one thing that might
have to adjust a little bit to the
environment at hand
yeah that's a that's a great point is
that we do not
there are settings where you might just
you know want to run it without the
grounding network and obviously that's
actually a simpler version so it should
be fairly easy to experiment with that
um
and also in the setting that you
describe
um
what will happen is like you say you
know the the the green the go to the
green door goal will get a lot of weight
um but hopefully can be counteracted to
some degree by the policy network which
will you know learn to not put any
weight on that once it realizes that
it's getting absolutely zero reward for
that setting but i agree that this kind
of introduces some weird training
dynamics that we don't really want it
might be cleaner just to remove the
grounding network entirely
um if if you
as as you said you you've looked at my
paper review a little bit i didn't go
too much into the experimental results
as such um is there also i didn't go
into the appendix at all because
honestly i haven't read the appendix
um because i uh sometimes
i don't i think
i should probably um but
is there anything that you want to
highlight specifically about the
experimental results or or maybe
something that you did in the exp
appendix which is
also has a lot of experiments in it um
you know things that you think people
should take away from the paper from the
experiment section
yeah so
um
broad takeaways are
uh and i think that you mentioned this
in the review is you know we're in these
kind of drl environments and and the
individual training runs are just
incredibly noisy you know and that can
be sometimes like rather difficult to
get a sense of oh is my method actually
working better than others right um but
there has been some great recent work um
from i think a team at mila
which won an outstanding paper award at
europe's last year which was called deep
reinforcement learning on the edge of
the statistical precipice and the basic
idea is you know we're compute
constrained we have these environments
they're very high variance but even
despite all of this
you know what are the kind of
statistical best principles that we can
follow to really see whether or not our
methods are actually making a measurable
and replicable difference uh in the
environments that we're testing
and so they have a lot of good
recommendations um which we try to
subscribe to as close as possible in
this setting right so um these training
curves here give you kind of a
qualitative sense about not only kind of
the ultimate performance attained by any
of the models but also of the
differences in sample efficiency that we
see right so it could be the case that
well ultimately um both amigo and el
amigo reach the same asymptotic
performance but amigo just gets there
faster or more reliably and that's
something that you can sorry l amigo
gets there faster more reliably and
that's something that you can look at in
these graphs but i think the more kind
of statistically rigorous way of
verifying that language is giving a gain
in the environments is in the subsequent
figure which is figure four which should
be right below this one i think
and this is really you know us trying to
statistically verify you know is there
an effect happening here and so these
here are
bootstrap confidence intervals um five
runs in each experimental condition and
we're plotting the 95 percent uh
confidence intervals for the
interquartile mean of models across
tasks so this is kind of like the mean
performance
assuming that you drop some of the
outliers because again these runs are
very high variance right and so this is
kind of a statistical recommendation
from the authors of that
deep rl paper
and we show that yes the individual runs
here you know have really high variance
naturally but as you begin to look at
the runs in aggregate across both the
mini grid and mini hack environment
suites we begin to see a trend that it's
clear that you know overall we're seeing
a good effect of language in these
environments
and so
this is a obviously these are aggregate
metrics overall
metrics and so on when we look at the
plots themselves there is quite
considerable
variance even in the in the ranks of the
method do you have an intuition of uh
between the the language methods which
works better in what kind of
environments and
in what kind of environments does
language even maybe hurt and why do you
have an idea yeah um
so
the trend that i try to highlight in the
paper is that in larger environments
language exploration does better
and the reason why you might expect this
is that in larger environments
uh amigo and novelty um kind of suffer
from this problem of increased noise
right there's a lot more coordinates for
example that you can propose which
essentially describe kind of the same
semantic action right you have like you
want to get the agent into one room of
this maze
and you know because the environment is
larger now there are four or five
different coordinates that all kind of
mean the same thing whereas as you
increase the size of the environment
uh the language set the set of language
goals is relatively more consistent
right it's kind of one of those uh
complexity analyses right it's like kind
of space complexity almost of the goal
space
and so you can see this trend happen a
bit
for example in the wand of death task so
wod this is in the top right corner here
we have w a day medium and wod hard
where in wod medium
amigo actually outperforms lmego it
actually gets you to higher performance
quicker whereas in
a wod wand of death hard
amigo is actually not able to learn at
all
and the only difference between these
environments it's fundamentally the same
task but the only difference is that in
wod hard
the room is a lot bigger so instead of a
narrow corridor you actually have to
search for the wand of death it's the
task
in some in some room beforehand and you
can see that just simply increasing you
know the size of the possible coordinate
spaces uh results in both uh traditional
novelty and traditional amigo doing much
worse in this environment and i think
that kind of shows that
these kind of state-based exploration
methods are very brittle to the size of
your state base right so you can kind of
increase your state space infinitely and
it'll make these methods perform worse
even if the underlying semantics of your
environment haven't changed yet
do you have an eye do you have a feeling
maybe if this is a property of the world
in general like let's say i as a human
right i'm put into a small whatever
environment or a big environment would
my descriptions of language also not
grow very much or is it a property of
just game developers you know i add a
few extra rooms i can reuse these
languages you know i just kind of tile
you know all the
the big games i mean the biggest games
are procedurally generated like
minecraft there it's really it's just
the same thing over and over but even in
like the like these big open world games
like grand theft auto or so
the same textures are reused and the
same cars and the same npc characters
right um is this a property of the world
or of the video game developers
yeah so this is a really deep
and almost philosophical question
yeah is something that i think about a
lot is
you can certainly and this is a totally
valid statement right you can say
well
there are a lot of language actions that
you can describe in our world and even
in the video game world which just
describe these like kind of infinitely
complex and nested sequences of actions
which have absolutely nothing to do with
the extrinsic task right i could tell
you to you know
you know run at the wall six times do a
360 and then you know continue hitting
the wall eight times right and that's
like a an incredibly difficult goal
which you can imagine a a very
structured curriculum to get to that
point right of just like infinitely kind
of bumping your head against the wall um
which satisfies you know maybe the
difficulty threshold of elemio but is
absolutely orthogonal to the task that
we care about um and i can imagine that
there are settings where the language is
kind of useless and doesn't end up you
know uh giving you any gains in this
setting and so there's kind of this open
question that we haven't really touched
on sufficiently in this paper which is
how good does the language have to be in
order to get this to work um so as i say
you know the language is is oracle it's
game developers but it also is noisy
there's a lot of actions like running
into walls or trying to throw stones at
a minotaur that are ultimately useless
in the environment
the argument we're making here is that
hopefully you know the noisiness of
language scales a little bit
less than the noisiness of your state
environment right but there's still a
lot of kind of edge cases in kind of
unexplored territory here
i think more philosophically if you
think about our world and our
environment right there are a lot of
ways that we can describe actions that
are not particularly useful in the world
that you and i inhabit right i mean i
can again tell you to do handstands and
hit a wall and you know
walk around and write endless you know
trivial things in the dust um but at the
same time there's a lot of our action
space in the real world that we simply
don't have language descriptions for
right so like every single precise
movement of my hand in my arm you know i
could presumably come with some language
to describe oh i'm actuating this joint
you know by 0.03 degrees and there's
like you know how many joints in my hand
right i mean there's like just endless
complexity in terms of the possible
action space just by moving a hand that
in language we have absolutely no words
for right and so it's it's really it's a
really tough question right like we have
a lot of kind of ways of describing
useless actions in the world but at the
same time it's very clear that the
language that we do use to describe the
world is operating at a higher level
abstraction than perhaps uh the kinds of
actions that rl agents have access to
right in for example actuating uh some
sort of limb or something
you make a you make a good point that in
the paper that language is a strong
prior over
what is essentially important to humans
right if i can describe something with a
short piece of language like of course i
can say do three backflips and then you
know do eight of that and so on but it's
a fairly complex sentence in itself uh
if i can describe something with a short
piece of language usually that is
something that
matters to some human
uh somewhere right otherwise that
wouldn't be mapped to a short string
but that brings me a bit to a different
question and that is the question of
isn't isn't the
i think in these environments there's
always a goal right there is one reward
at the end that you need to reach i can
imagine though that novelty or not
novelty in general or how how important
this state is is really dependent on
your goal you know whether i i
circumvent the minotaur at the you know
below or above that might not be
important if i want to reach whatever
the goal behind it
but it is really important maybe for a
different task you know uh
likewise i as a human whether i move
from here to there by walking forward or
backward doesn't matter if i want to get
to the fridge but it matters really if
i'm if i'm dancing right
so
is that something that
uh
like how does that interplay here with
these with these language
um things what do you do when a language
it almost like needs to incorporate a
piece of the goal that you want to reach
in order to be useful or not
yeah
so i think
thinking about or trying to filter the
language descriptions that you have to
language that is relevant for your task
is going to be important if we scale
this up to environments where it's clear
that using unfiltered language is not
helping right and again as i mentioned
the robustness of these kinds of
exploration methods to the noisiness or
relevance of your language signal is
still an open question
if we do have
task descriptions so we have extrinsic
cash descriptions like your job is to
you know defeat the minotaur
then it's yeah really intuitive that we
should be able to use that as a signal
for kind of weighting how relevant a
sub goal or language description that we
encounter
uh weighting how useful that is for the
extrinsic task right so if the extrinsic
goal is combat then we should be
prioritizing combat-related messages if
the extrinsic goal is buying something
then we should you know
promote acquiring money and things like
that and so that's something that i
think is a kind of natural extension of
this is you extend this to a multi-task
setting where you have task descriptions
and the task descriptions ought to kind
of heavily filter what some goals
should be relevant for the task i think
when you include task descriptions um
there are some more comparisons to
related work so there's you know been
some uh related work which you mentioned
the paper where let's imagine you're
doing basically hierarchical
reinforcement learning so you have some
extrinsic goal and then you want to
explicitly
decompose the extrinsic goal into sub
goals that you want to complete in order
right and that's those are certainly
kind of relevant
methods to to look at when you start
thinking about multitask or goal
condition settings
but
this is kind of a slightly different
focus where you know we're not trying to
identify sub goals that need to be
completed on the way to some extrinsic
goal um there's still kind of this
exploration component which is a bit of
a different use of language than this
kind of hierarchical stuff
but certainly i would say that there are
people who have looked at kind of
language conditioned rl and uh
hierarchical rl that think a lot and
very deeply about this problem of
proposing sub goals that are relevant
for the extrinsic goal assuming you have
some you know structured description of
what the extrinsic goal is
although i can imagine you run into
sort of the let's say the more abstract
problem of the exploration problem is
that you know without an outside signal
i don't really know what to do and there
is no clear let's say gradient towards
the goal right otherwise the exploration
problem in rl would be relatively easy
now when we say well we'll just filter
out all the messages that don't have
anything to do with our combat goal
right
it is like we could run into the exact
same thing again where you know maybe in
order to acquire a weapon i first need
money right that doesn't that's not
directly related to my combat goal so
there is like another exploration
problem again on top of the of the thing
we introduce
i guess maybe we can we can hope that if
we introduce enough levels the highest
level of abstraction will have uh a
small number of states so that that you
know random exploration works but it's
kind of funny that the problems repeat
or replicate yeah
yeah it's really tricky and that's
essentially just kind of a deeper or
more nested failure case of not knowing
what's novel and not knowing what's
relevant for your goal right so if
you're prioritizing words that have
combat in them because your extrinsic
goal is combat but you first need to buy
something then your your your semantics
you know your measure of novelty or
relevance is just not good enough right
and so that's going to just be a
fundamental problem in exploration is um
how do we know whether it's states or
language you know how do we know when a
state is relevant for the ultimate task
yeah and i guess humans aren't very much
different right i mean science is a
really hard process it's not you know
that exploration takes millions of
humans and and and hundreds of years so
we can't fault our rl agents here for
not not doing that great of a job um
here i found these plots to be really
cool like the analysis sort of the
evolution of what the teachers propose
and of course these being language it's
quite insightful and understandable
what's happening in the algorithm
my
my surprise was a little bit
aren't these things kind of subject to
like catastrophic forgetting or things
like this i i can imagine right if i
train these things online uh and they're
at some difficulty level all of a sudden
they forget that reaching the red door
is kind of really easy or so um is is
that have you ever thought
is that a problem or was that ever a
problem did you encounter that or why
don't we encounter that yeah
so
i expect that that is a problem that
happens in these agents i don't think we
really precisely tried to measure
whether or not catastrophic forgetting
is a problem
i think the the fact is that we evaluate
in environments where
we are not testing the agents kind of
continuously for mastery of all the
skills that it is learned
in its curriculum proposed by the
teacher and so this problem of oh you
know you forgot how to specifically open
a specific colored door is not an issue
as long as the student is still quite
good at completing whatever goals it
needs to complete to try to achieve
the extrinsic goal that is currently
being set by the teacher right and so if
you forget things that are at the very
beginning of training that's not a big
deal so long as whatever path that the
teacher is leading you on is something
that will eventually get you to the
extrinsic goal that we care about and i
think that happens to be the case in
these environments because there is only
one extrinsic goal and because we're not
testing it to you know master every
single skill from kind of low level to
high level abstractions um but if we
were in a setting where
being able to complete those lower level
goals kind of you know
on a dime
and kind of you know switch kind of do
context searching like that if that were
more important then we would have to
deal with this problem of catastrophic
forgetting right
an important point here is that we we
really don't care about how well the
student is able to follow instructions
proposed by the teacher um
that's i mean we hope the goal is that
that property emerges such that we can
complete the extrinsic goal right but
we're never actually trying to learn a
student that can follow instructions we
never really evaluate it exclusively in
an instruction following setting
um
let's if if we think ahead a little bit
and i'm gonna i'm gonna just scroll down
to the environment just because
uh
yeah maybe this this will inspire us a
little bit
if we think ahead a little bit
beyond this work uh here you have this
very this oracle language descriptor and
you say also in the outlook of future
work that that is something obviously
that we're trying to get rid of because
not every environment like the fewest of
environments actually have such a
built-in language description of our
easily accessible one so we might have
to
regress to something else so i wanna i
wanna think about three different
external models that we could bring in
and i wonder what you think of each of
them like how these could fit in the
first would be something like gpt3 like
just a pure language model how could
that help us um
maybe in in combination with with these
things because we need some starting
point right but how could a pre-trained
language model that know something about
the world help us then something like
clip maybe something that can you know
take an image and language and say
whether they're they're good together or
not and then maybe even something like
or or maybe a captioning model
um right
and maybe something like uh dali like
like something that takes language and
and generates is there in this cloud of
models um what possibilities do we have
to bring in sort of to replace this
oracle thing with uh with learned
systems it doesn't even need to be
learned online right it can be
pre-trained i'm probably much more
excited about that
yeah
um yeah these are i think going to be
the most fun questions to look at in
kind of language condition rl going
forward is taking the boom in
pre-trained models in large language
models
uh and resulting you know bringing these
into concrete and actionable gains in
reinforcement learning
uh it's funny that you mentioned
this kind of what i described as almost
a gradation from uh ungrounded language
models like gbt3 right which are trained
on text only corpora
and whether those can actually help in
these environments which i would call
are fundamentally grounded right they're
they're grounded in some some visual or
perceptual world um can ungrounded
language models still result in gains in
these settings and my intuition is yeah
they probably still can
because you know even if you don't
exactly know what it means to acquire a
wand or kill a minotaur in some
environment because you don't know what
a minotaur looks like or what a wan
looks like
gpt
as i mentioned you know this idea of
priors right gbt has strong priors on
sensible sequences of actions right so
insofar as these environments are
testing um kind of sequences of actions
that humans kind of have an intuition
for in you know it's some fantasy world
but we have some intuition oh in order
to defeat the minotaur we need to get a
weapon first we probably look around for
a weapon maybe there's a shop maybe we
can buy a weapon from the shop right uh
video games are testing knowledge that
we have very like deep-seated common
sense knowledge that we have that
hopefully generalizes to these fantasy
worlds uh and gpt certainly contains a
lot of that information right so you
might imagine we should reward or filter
the kinds of descriptions that we see
to those that seem sensible narratives
that gt3 would generate right so
a sensible sequence of actions along the
way to defeating the minotaur is
collecting a wand and buying it and
things like that
and i think you actually already see
some examples of this happening in more
goal condition or instruction following
rl so there's been some recent work from
i know teams at berkeley maybe google as
well that are looking at using
pre-trained language models which are
not necessarily even grounded they're
just you know gpt-3
using them to construct uh sensible
plans action plans or sub-goals for
completing certain actions so in some
home environment for example maybe my
action is
get a cup of coffee and then the goal of
gbt is even though i don't really know
what my environment looks like i don't
know what kitchen you're in i know that
sensibly this should you know include
finding a mug and then heating up the
kettle and things like that
and so we already see some promising use
of kind of ungrounded models for
improving uh grounded decision making
settings
um yeah did you want to comment on that
or i can also no that's that's that's
cool i think yeah um i've
i've i've i think i've even had one at
least one of these works uh here on the
on the channel in this in this home
environment that's exactly i was also
really cool to see
obviously these models know a lot about
the world right and i think people
overestimate how or underestimate maybe
well whatever
uh that the thing if we humans look at a
board like this like at a mini hackboard
we see a map right we see paths to walk
on and stuff like this even if we've
never played a video game
but this is these are such strong priors
built into us and we we sometimes think
like why can't that dumb computer just
like walk around the wall right like
what what's up but
um
and and i think these large models are a
way we can really get that knowledge
from the human world into into this
world so yeah i think that's uh
it's a great it's a great outlook also
with the the models that combine images
and text um i feel that could be that
could be a really
like adding a lot of value to the url uh
world at least
the rl environments that are like human
environments of course there's
reinforcement learning for uh
computer chip design
and things like this i don't think those
are necessarily going to be profiting
that much from it um but yeah
yeah uh really cool
is so you're you're at at stanford or
did you do the work at stanford or were
you at some internship yeah i did it
while i had an internship um last fall
so this is fall 2021 okay um continue
the work a little bit while at stanford
uh but it was mostly in collaboration
with some people at fair or meta i guess
now
um in in london
reinforcement learning is notoriously
also kind of hardware intensive although
this work right here seems like maybe
not that much could you describe a
little bit sort of
what what it takes to investigate a
project like this
yeah unfortunately i think even for
these environments it's fairly hardware
intensive
certainly still feasible i think
on let's say a more academically sized
compute budget but
for
being able to run the experimentation
needed to iterate quickly you know you
do really definitely benefit from kind
of industry level scale which is one of
the unfortunate things about this kind
of research is that it is a little bit
less accessible to people uh in
smaller compute settings um so
maybe
the typical kind of rl environments you
think of are compute heavy are the ones
that are in 3d simulation you know very
you know need physics needs soft joint
contact and all of these things to model
and those are really expensive i think
compared to that these are kind of more
symbolic grid worlds uh you know the
whole point as to why mini hack or net
hack was chosen as a reinforcement
learning testbed was because the code
base is you know written entirely in c
and is very optimized and so you can run
simulations very quickly
on modern hardware but that being said
it's still relatively uh compute
expensive again the just amount of
experience needed by state-of-the-art
deep rl methods even with extrinsic or
intrinsic exploration bonuses is still
very expensive right so for example one
of these runs we would typically have
let's say 40 cpu actors collecting
experience at the same time in parallel
and then kind of one or two gpu learner
threads in the background kind of
updating from
this experience so even just a single
you know uh
computational experiment here needs
non-trivial hardware for sure yeah and
and you ideally you want to do that in
parallel right because you want to try
out a bunch of things or repeat it a
bunch of times because yeah one
experiment really tells you
almost nothing right
unless it succeeds right if it succeeds
it's good but if it fails you never know
if you repeat it a bunch of times yeah
um but i mean it's still it's not it's
not the most extreme thing right uh like
two gpus or so and a bunch of cpus um as
as you say that can that's still
academically doable which i find cool uh
could you maybe
tell us a bit about the process of
researching of researching this like uh
did everything work out as planned from
the beginning or where was your starting
point um
and and what changed about your plan
during the research like maybe something
didn't work out or so yeah uh yeah i
feel
i don't i feel it's always good for
people to hear that other people
encounter problems and how they get
around problems yeah
yeah so
yeah uh it's a great question um the
intuition that i think me uh
and my collaborators started with was
you know um
fairly sensible it's
language is clearly going to help in
these environments um you know it has
some nice parallels to human exploration
and so let's just see whether or not
language will work in these environments
um what's funny though is that we
actually started out the project
less about the more abstract question of
like does language help exploration and
more a very concrete question of how do
we improve upon amigo so how do we
improve upon an existing
state-of-the-art algorithm for
exploration
let's propose something that we argue is
better than everything it's like we're
going to propose a state-of-the-art
exploration method called lmgo which
will get 100 accuracy in all these
environments and none of the existing
methods will work right that's that's
kind of the narrative that you set up
for yourself when you're starting
research is i'm going to build something
that's new and that's the best right
um
however i think this focus of this paper
and the story has shifted considerably
and i think it's shifted for the better
actually and part of this shift happened
because
we
implemented el amigo and it was working
fine and it worked better than amigo so
we were quite excited but at the same
time the field is moving so fast and
at eurips last year uh some researchers
came out with this method called novelty
and we ran novelty and novelty also did
really well
and you know in some environments it
totally like blew amigo out of the water
right
and al amigo and so part of our thinking
was well okay now we can't really say oh
we have el amigo and it's the best you
know model it's the best environment and
you should only use this
um and at first i thought you know this
is derailing our narrative right we're
not proposing anything new we're not
proposing anything state-of-the-art so
what's the point
um but i think after some kind of
juggling and shuffling we realized that
what we're really interested in is the
scientific question of does language
help exploration so take existing method
x and then do x plus language right
and that question can be answered kind
of agnostic to the specific method that
we actually use right and so it was that
juncture where we actually decided okay
let's actually you know look at novelty
closely and let's imagine adding
language to novelty as well and do we
see the same kind of results right and
so i think this is uh kind of an outcome
of the paper that was kind of you know
on the fly uh changed but i'm very happy
with which is that we're not trying to
claim that we have a method that is
state of the art or that is best or that
you know anyone should be using our
method
we are very agnostic to the particular
choice of method right we're trying to
answer kind of a more abstract
question which is when does language
help exploration
and i think this is a little bit more
egalitarian you know we're not saying
that our method is better than anyone
else's and we also don't have to exhaust
at least you know compared to like a lot
of existing work we're just saying that
if you take whatever method that we have
and you add language you do better and
here are two examples where that happens
cool
and it is a
it is a good way to uh preempt some
reviewers from saying that you didn't
train on imagenet and that's bad
yeah is there anything else that you
want to get
get out to viewers
maybe a way they can
they can get started if if that's
possible or anything that you'd like
them to know
um
yeah i think
i i think that um we've discussed a lot
about these kind of higher level ideas
of one holy grail is that we have clip
generating descriptions or open you know
gpt3 and then we're evaluating in these
really high dimensional spaces with
actual motor joints and we're gonna you
know
show how uh language helps um
in in these like mujoko style like
really deep rl you know realistic
environments and maybe you can transfer
to the real world i think that's the
broad vision but i think it is still
very far away i think you know we even
in this paper abstracted away a lot of
difficulty of the problem right we're
assuming that we have oracle language
annotations we're only looking at these
kind of symbolic grid worlds
and
although it's tempting to dive in and
say okay now let's kind of you know
straightforwardly let's extend this to a
real world environment where i have to
actually you know move my coffee mug to
make
coffee and tea i think we're still quite
far away from that you know broad vision
of kind of household enabled robots in
rl uh and
is probably not the most i think like
beginner-friendly way of starting right
it's just there's just so many deep
problems that need to be solved jointly
from perception to action to planning
and before we even consider how we
better you know incorporate language
into the mix and so i think the way to
build upon this work is just these kind
of very small progressive relaxations of
the assumptions that i and many of the
other people who have worked in this
space have right so again let's imagine
let's just imagine we get rid of the
oracle language annotator and we train a
model to emit states for these simple
environments you know we didn't really
explore that but that's a very sensible
way to extend this kind of work while
keeping the environment and the models
fixed right so this goes back to the
very beginning
when you mention yannick
the kind of way in which we
approach this paper was to keep
everything fixed and then just look at
this kind of very small change and see
how that results in you know different
performance in our environment
i think that's really just kind of the
way to go it's very slow it's very
incremental work but hopefully it's
getting us more towards that kind of
guiding star of eventually having these
models that operate in these realistic
environments and use you know
pre-trained model language to help
exploration
cool
well jesse thank you very much for being
here this was awesome
thanks yeah i had a lot of fun
[Music]
you